every news Outlet is just reporting on
problems so if you're looking for
problems just just go to any major
mainstream publication just see problems
and what most people do is they they see
the problems and they panic and they get
scared and they the media uses this as
opportunities to inject more fear
because you have to keep reading about
what the thing is because now I'm scared
for my life where the entrepreneurs and
and I I see that as an opportunity like
these are all opportunities anytime
there's there is pain and frustration
there's opportunities every great
business has been started by an
entrepreneur who saw a giant problem and
instead of complaining said huh maybe I
can fix that like I think it's never
been easier to be an entrepreneur and
win you can actually go and do whatever
you want you can actually go and build a
business where when your parents were 39
or my parents are 43 you had to be crazy
to be an entrepreneur you had to
basically be unemployable it's like you
can't get a job so your last resort is
to start your own business or you're
just crazy where now it's it's
completely possible hey it's EV car
Michael and I watch these videos every
day because I need them for motivation
being around successful entrepreneurs
every morning helps me believe that I
can do great things too it's like your
morning coffee but for your goals
kickstarting your day with a blast of
positivity so here is a challenge for
you try watching One video every morning
for the next 30 days and let's find out
together if they help you do great
things too if you're in leave a #
believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy rule number two is shift
your view on money I had to make money a
bigger priority because it's just been
Service as a
default um I believe humans are built to
serve period I think if you're not happy
in life it's because you're not serving
and we all want to wake up and feel like
today matters that what we're going to
make today matter everybody every human
whether we want to you and I want to
impact the world want to have a big
giant Mission impact but some people
just want to serve the 25 close closest
people to them but either way everybody
every human wants to feel like they
matter that they're going to make
something today that will have an impact
on somebody else's life great that has
to be number one money is a is a is a
funny thing I don't think most people
grow up with a healthy perspective on
money uh myself included I think some
people think money is everything money
is the only thing that matters that next
person coming into the to my store
that's my next suit that's my next car
that's my next purse whatever and other
people think money is the root of all
you know evil we've all heard the
expression it's actually the love of
money is root of all evil but we forget
that part it's just shorten it till
money is root of all evil and and it's
not money is not evil money is a tool
you need you need money to do anything
even Charities need money to operate and
so how I've come to interpret it for
myself and then teach others is money
has to be in your top
five if if you're an entrepreneur if you
want to have success of any kind money
has to be in your top five even if
you're a chair money has to be in your
top five it just can't be number one
number one is your mission number one is
the purpose number one is the impact
that you had on that one girl because in
that one girl there's millions of people
who are like that who will be moved by
your message um but how can you I used
to fight with how do I do both like how
do I but I want to make money but I want
to have impact but I want to make money
but but they work together they're not
opposite they're not conflicting the
more money you make the more people you
can go serve if you you know back then
could turn that part-time speaking thing
into a full-time career with a team of
people you're going to reach more people
me right now having 36 people on my team
I can reach way more people than just
Evan karco by himself making a video
yeah and so I had to come up I came more
from the money is everybody had money
were kind of selfish or greedy or did
something to cheat people um so money is
more the root of of evil and I had to
put into my top five but if you got it
number one just Just Bounce It keep it
it's important Just Bounce It from the
top spot cuz there's something more
important rule number three is find your
passion every successful business is a
combination of what you love doing with
what gives value to people if you love
it but it doesn't serve anybody you've
got a hobby right it could be really
fulfilling hobby it makes you feel great
to sit in your basement playing a guitar
but if it's not bringing value to
anybody it's just a
hobby some people go the other way and
they're only chasing what there's
opportunity in but they don't love it
like don't go chasing nfts or Clubhouse
or crypto if you don't love it because
you're G to get you're G to get
destroyed by the people who actually
love it right and so it's in that
intersection of what do I love doing
that can that can be of service and
bring value to other people and that
that's this the success story of every
single entrepreneur who's made it they
love the thing and it brings value to
people so if you love it awesome now you
got to figure out how do I use my my
skill set my talent what I live doing to
help other people Rule Number Four is
learn to prioritize there's so many
things that you could do right what most
people get wrong is just the sequence so
like the steps yeah I want the sequence
in what order to do it in so ultimately
the goal is to do everything but the
path to be able to do everything is to
do one thing yes to start Focus because
if you try to do
everything nothing happens it's it's
like all of these little tiny things you
do a little in Chinese and a little in
English and you still have you care for
your father and you still have your job
like all spre and then like nothing ends
up happening little bits of all these
things so ultimately to accomplish your
mission you're going to need to be able
to do this full-time and then you're
going to need to have a team so it's not
just you doing everything right yeah at
the beginning it's you part-time because
you're doing other stuff right great so
in our part-time hours how do we get the
most out of the few hours that you have
every day to work on this to generate
enough money that you can then leave the
job to then generate more money so you
can hire team to then help you do the
big thing right right so we want to do
everything I love it you know it's great
yes thank you and what's the market to
go after that will pay you fastest
inside your mission not just like go get
another job but inside of what you want
to do is it English Market is it Chinese
market is it selling a specific course
or program or training or coaching
what's the thing that can generate the
fastest Revenue inside your mission so
you can leave your job and do the full
time also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is stop making
excuses you know what was your process
when you first started how did it evolve
in terms of the videos that you were
making initially and the quality what
did you start with what was your type of
equipment and how has that kind of
evolved because it's an interesting uh I
want I want people to see the journey
that you know people see you now but you
weren't always like at this
position yeah in terms of equipment just
start you know I will still make videos
off of my iPhone right and I've got
three million subscribers and half a
billion views or whatever is on the
channel uh I'll still make some videos
off my iPhone don't let the fear of the
of the of the lack of knowledge the lack
of gear be the thing that prevents you
from getting started you've got a great
idea a great Mission a great heart and
your excuses for why you can't can't do
it is the only thing that's separating
you from the people who are off- winning
um for any of those people who say oh
that person won off of my idea well it's
not your idea you didn't they had the
same idea it's not like they came and
tapped your brain while you were
dreaming and then sucked it out and sort
of they just did something with it and
I'm really passionate about this tent
because I think a lot of
people have that have that good heart
you want to serve because you're so
afraid and meanwhile dummies are winning
off of your idea dummies with less
ambition less intent less heart less of
a desire to serve they're winning off of
your idea because you are too afraid and
they just got started right you know uh
the plan is never the plan like whenever
you start something you can have a great
plan of how you think it's going to work
out great that's not how it's going to
work out you're GNA have to adjust a
million times like that's the story of
an entrepreneur it's the ability to
adjust to the circumstances rule number
six is Trust your intuition why say yes
to uh the little people if you
will so probably multi-part answer in
that one too you guys asking some good
ones um for me it's always a Vibe thing
so my team is probably upset that I'm
doing this I'm sure I'm sure you know my
team probably has all sorts of things
that they would love to have me on and
I'm behind on a million projects and you
know I mean they'll be happy eventually
though Evan they'll be happy eventually
I promise
[Laughter]
yeah just the the the demands on the
time as you get busier and bigger you
know that's one of the hardest things to
constantly figure out um and my biggest
fear is disappointing people and letting
people down and
and part that happens every day you know
like people would email me their cover
or DM me and I never see it because we
get just it's not possible to see
everything that comes in and that
somebody might be disappointed by that
you know tears me up and I have to keep
going um so why do I say yes it's it's a
Vibe thing I say yes to things that I
shouldn't say yes to but it just feels
right so I say yes to it and then don't
judge it afterwards maybe maybe it's the
greatest interview of all time with gut
check so that was a win or maybe it just
sucked right and and I I made the wrong
call somewhere and and next move on but
I don't look back and say oh I wish I I
did this or didn't do that um so I say
yes to People based off of a Vibe period
you know awesome um I say yes to I said
yes to write my book based off of a Vibe
I said yes to making some videos just it
just feels right and I got into the
habit of not judging what feels right
and just doing it even though it doesn't
make sense just say yes and go instead
of getting locked up in procrastination
mode and judging this versus that it's
like how do I feel that one perfect
that's what we're doing um and as a
logical like I love I like thinking
through things
that's that didn't come natural but I
had to learn just to trust the intuition
trust the feeling rule number seven is
stop being afraid we don't think about
the future regret enough because the
starting the thing is painful because
there's a chance of rejection there's a
chance of it not working out um you know
as an example like real live moment
right now so just before this show I was
talking to Mark Randolph on my Instagram
live we doing an interview with him from
my YouTube channel and and he's the
co-founder of
Netflix and so when that came across my
table I like do you want to interview
Mark Randall for your channel do you
want to have a conversation with the
co-founder of Netflix I'm like yes but
then immediately all of the fears said
like oh my gosh I don't know anything
about him I I don't what if I ask a
stupid question what if I don't and so
there's a tendency to then go instantly
into delay like yeah I like that but
let's I'll do it how about next month or
next whatever and you just you push it
off but really it's because I'm afraid
I'm just afraid right I'm afraid of of
especially in a live setting right it's
not like it's pre-recorded this is gonna
be a live setting with a live audience
what if I just ask something stupid or
or something happens and this is still
20 this is still now this is just just
happened eight minutes ago right so it's
not like I'm over this and it was
something that looking back 10 years
later but I constantly remind myself
that I want to jump into the things that
make me afraid especially if the fear is
other people's opinions right like if
you're afraid of jumping into a uh an
alligator's mouth okay yes that's a good
like you should be afraid of that course
that's probably stupid you know don't do
that but but being afraid to be on stage
or to make a video or to do an interview
or to launch your program is really just
fear of other people's opinions
judgments expectations and as long as
you live inside that fear you will never
never do anything Great rule number
eight is change your environment what
are some things that people can do to
you know always take their belief to the
next level what are some of the things
that you're doing consistently to
consistently build that belief so they
can get it to that that level where it's
like until it becomes their reality that
what their goals are yeah I mean I know
we got a pop but but two quick things
one is to start to surround yourself
more with the people who are embodying
that belief right so and whatever it's
not just believe in yourself whatever
you want more you want more courage be
around more courageous people you know
if I want to be a better parent I'm
going to hang out with my parents more
if I want to be a better Visionary I'm
gonna hang out with you know Steve Jobs
more and and I can't meet Steve Jobs but
there there's enough of his content out
there that you can be around it and
learn it uh so that's step number one if
you love Tyler great if Tyler makes you
feel like things are possible Tyler
gives you more courage or commitment to
Excellence follow him subscribe to his
shows be have Tyler if Tyler was living
with you every day you're going to grow
and you're G to get more courageous and
have more commit Excellence so so have
him live with you by watching all his
stuff constantly so I'm around Elon Musk
and Steve Jobs and Oprah winfy and these
people every day it's what I needed when
I was 19 and it's still what I need
today at 40 and and that's why I do what
I do so step number one is is to
radically change your environment to to
have the people from from the things
that are on your wall to the what's in
your Instagram feed your YouTube feed
from the from the clothes that you wear
to the the thing that you're drinking
right like all of it is is is a reminder
of who you want to be and then so that's
that that gives you the framework to
start to feel it more step two is and
there's only two steps you got to do
something right like you could watch
Tyler all day long and get courage great
but now you gotta Tyler's not going to
come and make the call for you Tyler's
not going to come and launch that drink
company for you Tyler's not going to
come and right so you have to do it
right but what what Tyler can do what I
can do what whoever can do is give you
that little bit of motivation that
little bit of courage to then take the
step and to build momentum so you need
that motivation daily because you might
be super fired up and inspired today
awesome you're GNA wake up tomorrow and
go back to not having as much courage
and confidence and belief and so you
need that as part of your daily routine
to get you inspired to the point where
you do where you take the action that
you're afraid to do rule number nine is
be a great leader to be a great leader
you have to care more about the people
on your
team as humans than you care about them
winning in your business you need them
to win as people more than win with you
and I see everybody that we meet we're
we're on these parallel paths together
so us here we're we're on this parallel
path for this you know 20 25 minutes
together and maybe I never see you again
maybe we launch the greatest joint
venture of all time you know we but
right now we're on this parallel path of
this of this show and everybody who
comes into your life into your
businesses uh you're on a parallel path
with them and your goal should be to
understand what their goals are and help
them accomplish it and sometimes that's
with you sometimes the best thing they
can do is be with you for the rest of
your lives because you make each other
better maybe the two of you make each
other better you complement each other
you bounce off each other and you're
better together than you are
individually
but maybe at some point the person with
you should leave they'd actually be
better served going somewhere else that
they love working with you but it's
actually limiting them because they're
they've got something greater calling
them that you have to go push them away
to go off and do and I think that is the
core of leadership when you can love
people and want them to win more than
you want them to win with you when
people feel
that you get the hearts and their souls
where most people just show up with
their brains you get everything because
they know that you want them to win and
they're not
questioning the Loyalty yeah right and
um that's that's that's hard and that's
not I don't think taught in in schools
but really you just have to care for the
person in front of
you and want them to win as a person and
if you make that your goal that if
people are around me they're going to
level up any body who comes in contact
with me has to level up if you're on my
team you need to level up as a person
otherwise I'm a failure as a lead I
don't care if you did all the work that
you were supposed to do if you're still
mindset wise habit wise routine wise in
the same spot that you were last year
that's my fault and it's accepting
responsibility for their lives I think
that's a good leader I think that's a
good husband I think that's a good
father I think that's what leaders do
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is keep
serving the more you do it and the more
you start to see like you'll start to
get hooked on it too but it at the
beginning I didn't do it as much as I do
now but then when you do a little bit
like when you pour belief into one
person and then a year later or six
months later whatever they come back and
they say dude like I took your advice
and look what I made and then they give
you all the credit you're going to do
the same thing as like nah like I'm 1%
like you did the work but when you see
that it's so fun to see it come back in
six months or a year or whatever to see
their growth that it just makes you want
to go and find more people to do the
same thing with because it doesn't take
that much time like how much time did I
actually invest in into your podcast not
a lot like it's it's an hour two I don't
know what we spent well we had to
actually redo episode number one because
I messed up on something so it was like
two hours maybe sure but like two hours
how many years ago is that you know yeah
not that long I mean it's a I we haven't
we've been in touch but it's not like
were chatting every day and that had a
huge impact to to be able to shift
somebody's life in an hour or 25 minutes
or 15 minutes like to know that you can
do that and it's then they have the
ripple effect or butterfly effect the
more that you see that come back the
more it just makes you want to keep
doing
it what do you think would gravitate
towards negativity a lot more when we
know it doesn't make us feel good
because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like it's like from the history of
US struggling right has to be you I mean
I don't know I don't not I'm not a
scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but like why
do we slow down and look at a car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally get hit by looking
at somebody like if a fight breaks out
on the street is like you're you know
you want to see what happens like where
we are I don't know where comes from but
like it it it definitely is that people
would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video was the top 10 rules
for Kanye West and was positive things
you can learn from Kanye if that was a
negative like top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said it would it would do so
much better because I think I think if
I'm looking at it from the perspective
of what I do it's like we we would
rather see people fail than than try to
build ourselves up
right you know it's like oh look at D
she she's got her podcast and she's been
on movies and look at her building her
life and she she made it out and now
she's in LA and she's such a big deal
and yada y y and it's easier for me to
try to tear you down and want to see you
fail then for me to say huh like maybe I
can fix my life maybe I can go to La too
maybe I can start a podcast maybe I can
and and whatever the things are that you
know jealousy is really just um in
inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if I if I'm jealous of
you I'm actually inspired by you but I
don't know how to handle it so I take it
negative
totally so it's easier for me to tear
you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because I don't have to do any
work that way right it's like yeah but
then yeah but she like totally sold her
soul to go do that and she and I'll make
I make up someu that like doesn't even
make sense but it allows me to stay
where I'm at where I am right so that's
why a lot of a lot of even our friends
and family will often say not to go do
something because if you go off if you
go off to LA and you start becoming a
movie star and you start meeting people
what does it mean for
me you know like you left me behind and
and now my life sucks because you're
showing what's possible and I'm living
in a fake reality I don't want to accept
that
so it's not possible you must have had
to do something super
scammy terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know you hide
someone in the closet and it's not
coming out yeah so I think that's like
it we don't doing work on yourself is
hard very learning new skills and making
new connections and going to a new
country or new city is hard it's really
hard and we don't want to do hard things
but your great life is on the other side
of of hard things
and so when we see somebody else who
looks like us comes from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than Be
Inspired not everybody but a lot of
people yeah because we want we prefer to
stay stuck than the grow how do you
create a business from all this that
you've been doing and then it becomes
something quite quite quite quite REM
remarkable yeah I think there's lots of
ways to win I think it's more what do
you want to do so I like helping people
so I like I like doing courses but not
just a course but I like I like training
I like I like having somebody in front
of me I like not just here's this course
I never have to see you again I like
seeing the person and coaching them and
guiding them even just before this I was
I was leading my community and it it
actually used to be a course but then I
stopped it as a course and turned it
into a membership because people are in
a course but I never got to see them I
didn't get the I didn't get to see the
results of what they were doing and now
I get to meet people every week and see
what they're up to and how I can help
but that's that's not necessarily the
best way to do it it's what do you love
doing so you could sell courses you can
sell Consulting you can sell your
products you can sell your services you
can sell your books you can sell your
speaking you can sell your hosting like
there's so many things you could sell
what is that you actually want to sell
that you love doing but I think it's
really important that when you are
getting started
that you actually think about how can
you turn this into a business how can
you so that you're not just wasting time
like I I could have dra grown a lot
faster in the early days of my channel
too if I thought about it like a
business and there were less
opportunities there less ways to do it
compared to right now but a lot of
people just oh I just want to be famous
okay but how are we gonna make money
doing the thing that you're creating
because if it's just a hobby most people
will probably quit if you can't figure
out a way to make money most people will
probably quit on the thing and so it's
like how do you you have your purpose
and your mission and I love it yes and
inside of that how can we start to make
money as soon as possible so that you
can stay dedicated to it how do you
personally set goals and then what
happens if you don't hit a goal because
like it does happen sometimes and like
obviously what matters is what you do
about it so so here's the thing so I
don't most of my goals are habits
they're not like I want to make x amount
of money by the end of the year it's the
habits right so it's not I want to be
able to lift x amount it's I want to I
want to be spending half an hour in the
gym every day or I want to make sure I'm
waking up at this time every day it's
the habits you can check out and say I
did
that so I think that's where most people
will mess up on their goals it's it's
the daily habits you are what you
consistently do it's not about achieving
that outcome it's about being the person
who can achieve that outcome and that's
by setting daily and weekly consistent
habits for yourself if you don't hit it
for some
reason then the big question is are you
proud of the reason
why so I had a guy I'm doing this tour
right now I'm driving in the car between
Sacramento and and Salt Lake City
somewhere in Nevada right now desert
this wild uh I had a guy in my Columbus
stop and he said hey Evan I I had a goal
that I wanna I want to do six days a
week cold showers okay one day off
Saturday off six days a week cold
showers it was Friday night my workshop
he said my heat's been out all day I've
been at my girlfriend's house all day
her heat was off and so I've been
freezing all day long and so I I didn't
do my cold shower like I said I would
should I do my cold
shower I said well are you proud of the
reason why you didn't do
it he said no okay then you have to go
take a cold shower and then tomorrow you
have to take another cold shower even
though it's your day off just to show
yourself what you're capable of and so
when you don't do something it's are you
proud of the reason why not right so
like I'm on this tour right now 90 days
cities I'm I'm two-thirds of the way
through as we're
talking I've committed to going to the
cities I've sold tickets in these
different cities you know if my mom went
to the
hospital tomorrow for something I would
cancel my tour and go home and be with
my mom I didn't follow through my goals
I didn't didn't do what I said I was
going to do I'm disappointing a whole
bunch of people who bought tickets and I
do my best to make it up to them but I'm
not going to make everybody happy like
some people will be pissed at me yeah
but am I proud of the reason why I
didn't do my goal hell yeah so I'm okay
with it right so when you set a goal you
have to follow through and if you don't
then then are you proud of the reason
why not and if you're not then you have
to come back twice as strong the next
day just to show yourself are you of the
opinion then that if somebody has a job
but they have a feeling that they want
to be um an entrepreneur but they're
afraid of leaving their job are you of
the opinion that they should uh take a
take steps towards that and and if you
have a feeling for something try
it and just see and expect to suck but
at least you tried and you can see you
know do you want to go off and do it
again you had a feeling in in the coffee
shop to come and ask me to connect if
you didn't follow the feeling that would
have been it like I would have my my
breakfast with Joe and then ciao and off
right and I may never see you again you
had the feeling you followed it and it
may not always be good like maybe I'm an
maybe I'm an ass maybe you're like dude
get out of my face you're weird stalking
me out of the bathroom right like maybe
like you don't know you don't know what
would happen but you have a feeling and
you have to follow the feeling cuz
otherwise you teach yourself that the
things that come to you are not great
because if every time you get an idea
and you don't follow through you're
teaching yourself that your ideas suck
versus I have an idea I'm going to give
it a shot that's a great identity to
start to build it doesn't mean go
mortgage your home to go start a podcast
Studio like expect to suck and find the
smallest possible thing to just go and
get started so somebody who's working a
corporate job that hates their life okay
you're you're never going to win doing
work that you hate so so longer term
something has to change it doesn't mean
go like take a flamethrower to your
boss's office or something now like you
need the money you need the cool awesome
but longer term like we have to make a
change somewhere because you will never
be great doing work that you hate you're
never going to make the money never
going to be happy if you're doing work
you hate every day so how are you going
to get out of that hole that you're in
is it going to be somebody else telling
you what you should do with your life
that's going to be like you have ideas
for what you it'd be cool if I could do
this okay go give it a shot try it see
if you liked it your first podcast
sucked cool and you get better like
you're better at eight episodes in than
I was at like 300 episodes in right so
but you try and so I think if you have
the feeling you want to teach yourself
that you come up with great ideas and
and they're worth at least giving a shot
to instead of just saying you know
there's sushi on the table I don't like
sushi without even giving a shot because
it sounds gross like if you had to
explain what Sushi is raw fish with with
fish eggs and seaweed with rice and
super spicy mustard that doesn't sound
appetizing right like why would anybody
eat that but you eat it I like Su with
you guys but but you don't know until
you try so like you're judging things
before you're trying it and especially
when it's yourself you're judging your
ideas before you even try it you're
building uh the belief that your ideas
suck and that you suck and then you stay
stuck and so I I at least you know
encourage myself to try to flip that
that I have ideas that saying yes to you
okay let's go I'm not going to judge it
let's go do it a lot of people tend to
say put others before you put yourself
and for me I've always thought that
wasn't the necessary correct way for me
to operate I know that when I put myself
first when I take care of my health and
when I make sure that I'm living in
alignment with my dreams I serve others
better then versus putting them first
and then me suffering and so for you has
that been something that's been natural
to you I think it's all learned
behavior uh I think my parents started
me off early with just how they lived
and and being an inspiration I think
humans are built to serve period like I
think if you're not happy in life it's
because you're not serving somebody gota
and some people are built to serve the
world like chances are the two of us
we're built to Ser we want to have a big
impact we want our our reach to be wide
we have a message that needs to be heard
yeah but some people are just built to
serve the 25 closest people to
them perfect my wife is more like that's
it she wants to she's still in contact
with her friends from kindergarten but
but doesn't have a message that she
wants to share with the world that's
right still buil to serve if you're not
happy because you're not you're not
serving others so the it's the same
thing when you're happy you're you're
capable of serving more people when
you're growing when you've taken another
step on the staircase you can pull more
people up to join you on that
step but if you're stay at the ground
level you can't you can only help people
with things you've gone through and
grown through right so the more you grow
and learn the more you can pull people
up and and help them and that's
ultimately what's GNA like I said your
purpose comes from your pain the more
you struggle and suffer and then grow
the more you'll be able to help other
people go through that same thing so I
see them as the same
thing investing in yourself and learning
getting better and struggling allows you
then to help others but it's based off
of a default premise that people are
good like I believe humans are good and
and that we're built to serve that's
amazing and that if somebody's doing
something that's negative or wrong or
insulting or imagine if you assume that
so for example in La my car was
everything my car was stolen I was on my
I was on my tour um they stole my gear
my signs my wallet my phone like they
stole everything in the car giant
Suburban rated wow in a in a private
parking lot um I think those people are
good people who are built to serve like
whoever stole from my car they're good
people who are built to serve I just
believe that how do you uh make your
team better like how do you like to go
ahead and try and make improve your team
day today I think it's carrying about
them as people wanting them to win as
humans more than you want them to win
with you
I want the people on my team to win as
people more than I want them to win with
me now quite often it's a similar path
it's like hey you want to do this your
best path is to stay with me and I'll
help you get there but it may mean that
they have to leave and go do something
else right like Zan if you watch our our
live stream xan is my co-host yeah um I
want xan to
win more than I want him to win with me
and that may mean he has to jump off at
some point and not be my coach co-host
on this stream if I ever felt like me
being with Zay on the stream wasn't in
his best interest I would kick him out I
would kick him out it's like Dan I love
you you can't be here anymore you have
to go do that thing I'm not gonna let
you stay here you have to go off and do
that thing it's it's even though he's
bringing so much value to me it's
actually holding him back if I felt I
don't feel that way I think it's great
for him but if I did I push him away
towards the thing that he should be
doing and when you when you do that most
people only think what can this person
do for me when you think what does this
person need and how can I help them
often again there's parallel
paths but at some point some people may
have to divert and go do something else
maybe somebody's with you for life maybe
somebody's with you for 10 years maybe
someone's with you for 10 months or 10
hours and and they have to go off and do
their thing but while we're together I'm
I just want you to win as a human and
when people feel that you get their not
just their brain but you get their heart
and their Soul how you started to create
your YouTube channel because me myself
along with many other YouTubers out
there are people who want to build their
YouTube following H how what do we do
how do how do we start to build and grow
our YouTube channel one is you just
start I think people are in their head
too much I think
people they're trying to be perfect
you're you're some big impossible plan
up in your head and then as a result you
don't do anything so you need to start
you need
phone film your phone up turn it
sideways and start to film and post your
first video right what
Marlo first is going to be terrible like
ever in your life like you got up on a
bicycle and you fell off you know you
didn't just get up and ride so don't
expect to get on YouTube and be great on
camera you know you you could have great
like even you you've got great speaking
skills and you're great with people and
you love interviewing you love talking
it's still a learning process to get
great in front of the camera some people
can short shortcut that path but it's
still a path and so just start get out
of your way stop being perfect expect it
to suck and just start two I would say
you need to be consistent so it doesn't
matter where you start where you start
is not going to be where you finish but
you have to move and you got to move
consistently and so there was a great
quote I think it was Will Smith but was
talking about how I'm not responsible
for where I started you know I was born
where I was born I can't change that but
I'm responsible for where I finish I get
to control where I go in life no matter
where I started and so people blame
their start and then they don't move but
it's like it's on you doesn't matter
where you came from you you can go
anywhere uh and so consistency you got
to practice you got to get better you
got to make daily content if you want to
get good at something if you want to if
you want to be Oprah Winfree level
Talent at something you have to do it
daily you know if you if you are making
a video a week you're just never going
to get world class at that thing just
like anything else if you if you did
anything else once a week you would
never become world class at that thing
might get decently good if you want to
be a chef and you're only practicing
cooking once a week you're never going
to be the oper Winfrey of cook of of
that right you're never going to do it
so you need to practice more so one just
start start with what you have start
immediately today like happy New Year
let's start right now today we're going
we're not waiting and then every day you
need to practice you need to practice
practice and you will slowly get better
I've had people who leave my channel
because I've made videos on Trump I made
videos on on Clinton the Clinton the
Trump one well the Trump one was one of
my favorites of yours as
well great I mean you're people are very
in their in their bias camps but I I
like that some people are crossing over
just just the willingness to learn I
think that's how you actually solve
problems absolutely the guy who grew up
thinking black people were the nword and
now was willing to learn like now we're
we're changing perspectives we're
getting somewhere I didn't set out to
try to solve racism but now it's a
little tiny piece of of the solution
absolutely I love it so like somebody
had
enough uh Equity or confidence in
me that their entire background growing
up with their parents and saying like
these people are the worst humans alive
and you can't learn anything from them
but Evan suggested that I watch his
video he's put up on his channel for a
reason that brief moment of confidence
LED this guy to watch the video and now
he he changes perspective um that's I'm
proud of that I'm happy that I did I'm
proud of myself for that even though I
may lose some people who who will say
never profile a black person on your
channel they got nothing to teach you
that's right like I'll lot those people
okay but maybe I'll convert some of them
over absolutely absolutely ab and it's
very common that this is part of my
ninja whole strategy behind the channel
that's evolved my ninja strategy people
come in who to find people who look like
them it it just is like like guys will
gravitate towards guys women towards
women Tech entrepreneurs towards Tech
all of it whoever's like you you want to
go and learn it's just natural yeah but
I want I want to have those people bring
you in and then introduce other people
who don't look like you who don't come
from the same industry or the same
background and challenge you to try to
learn from that person I think that's
where the real learning comes and I
think that's where tolerance and
understanding and patience is built why
is there so much negativity in the
system well it's because there's a lot
of pain in the system uh when you've
been in pain did you always show up as
your best self did you show up and do
things that you were super proud of when
you were hurting in a lot of pain right
probably not right like you all you come
out and you do a lot of negative things
sometimes and so just understanding that
can can take a lot of the sting out of
people's words this isn't a bad person
this isn't a toxic person they're just
in a lot of pain and we expect people
who are in pain to to lash out and do
bad things um anyway once you figure out
what that who is that serves you for
life so if yours is believe then now you
know the kinds of people who you need on
your team if you're going to hire a
video editor it's great if they have all
the skill sets of how to cut videos
together but they better love belief
they better they better be a person who
likes Bel it doesn't necessarily have to
be their who but it's got to be pretty
close so now you know the kinds of
people that you want to attract into
your life you know the message that you
want to put out there to the world it
becomes the lens through which you see
the world and anytime that you're not
happy it's because there's a lack of
belief somewhere lack of belief in
yourself lack of belief in the
relationships around you lack of belief
in the team members that you've got um
lack of belief in the projects that
you've got going on that leads to
unhappiness and so it's also a quick fix
you we just need to have more belief in
the system for us to be happy and that's
for anybody figure out you're who it
gives you that road map for happiness
for the rest of your life it it doesn't
get old like that Tina will be 120 years
old still believing in other people it's
not going to be like oh this year I'm
gonna switch it to something else like
no that's who you are the idea with 2%
difference is when we come up with an
idea like I'm going to launch a YouTube
channel I'm going to write my own book I
want to start a Instagram book account
like I want to do whatever we all have
these ideas of what we want to do the
first thing that we typically do is
start planning researching planning
who's done it before who can I model and
learn from all these ideas and we create
this giant list of plans and what we're
trying to do is plan to the 100% which
is like that's what our final
destination is going to look like how do
I plan to get my goal and then we end up
waking up the next day and you look at
your plan like I can't do that I thought
what I'm not that there's no way I can
do that it's not even like us telling
our friends or our spouses or it's it's
us telling ourselves that we can't do
this and so the problem is we used our
energy our our our mojo our our best
like high Vibes on planning instead of
on doing where again the biggest thing
people are missing just momentum
planning doesn't really count as
momentum you have to go and do something
and so instead of worrying about
planning to get to 100% of our goal
completed the 2% difference is just the
first 2% what's what's the first 2% and
we don't care about getting to the end
goal we just care about getting started
so that was me in writing the book okay
well I'm going to write the book after
this Instagram live I'm going to start
right now it's easy for all the thoughts
to start to overwhelm yourself and I did
like I don't have time for this I this
is not on my plan I'm busy I have to I
feel like I'm going to be a bad father a
bad husband a bad uh manager a bad CEO
like I don't have time for this right
and I share those thoughts in the book
too so you can kind of peek behind the
window it wasn't like I really was
desperately wanting to do this going in
and then uh I just started writing so
like if anybody out here you want to
write your first book cool the the 2%
difference is write the first page and
it's okay if it sucks if you want to
start a YouTube channel the 2%
difference is record your first video
and it's going to suck awesome cool but
more important than planning how to make
a book or planning how to record a
YouTube video is to just start doing the
thing and you build momentum if you want
to start building a healthy habit you
want to you want to you want to start
working out right this is where we often
get overwhelmed like I want to work out
I want to look good next year I want to
I want to feel comfortable naked or
whatever we want to be able to do cool
so it starts off with this very simple
concept but then the doing becomes
really complicated because as you start
to plan and research a health Journey
right it's like oh well do I do weights
do I do cardio how much of each do I do
uh do I do classes do I hire a coach do
I how much am I supposed to wait am I
going to hurt myself am I going to
injure my back trying to do this thing
maybe I should take maybe I should go do
soccer or pick up a sport or pick up uh
basketball or oh but do I need a partner
to run with like it can I overtrain and
how about nutrition like do I need to
drink am I drinking too much water not
enough water do I need to go carnivore
or vegan and all of a sudden it's like
so many this is what happens we get so
overwhelmed with all the potential
options which then us to try to plan
plan plan plan plan plan plan some more
but then you can't understand all of the
various options and then we end up
getting this is C I'm not doing I'm I'm
out I'm done and then you stop before
you even started right and so the key is
2% difference if you want to start a
health Journey get down on the floor and
do five push-ups or 10 or two right is
it going to make you extra strong no but
it's the first step and most people wait
a decade to take the first step and so
that's what the 2% difference difference
is all about do you believe we're born
to do something or do we just find
something along the way I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at
something most people never find
it uh I believe even the the greatest
basketball player of all time isn't
Michael Jordan it's somebody you've
never heard of it's a manager at
Starbucks cuz he never picked up a
basketball and so he could have been the
greatest of all time and instead he's a
manager at Starbucks and he's okay with
his life instead of being great at
something and so I don't know you know I
don't I don't know about the words
destined or anything like that but I I
believe everybody has that kind of
talent you have genius level Talent at
something and you've got to go and
figure out what that is and it's it's
your responsibility not just to yourself
but to your community to your family to
the people around you to the world to
then share it share that gift and so
part of the path to finding it is just
trying things
you know maybe not everybody should be
an entrepreneur but everybody should try
it you should try it and see like did I
like that did I was that fun was that
enjoyable do I want to keep doing that
and if it's not great then go do
something else I think too many people
don't try enough things we get locked
into a career path way too soon and then
you don't know how to get off of it and
then the further on you get the more
responsibilities you have the more
difficult it is to jump off and do your
own thing and so I think it's
everybody's responsibility first to
themselves to have a happy life to
figure out what they have Michael Jordan
level Talent at what skills does someone
need to get into this area of wanting to
be an entrepreneur what does it take I
don't think skills are the problem I
think I think you can learn anything if
you have a a commitment and passion to
learn um learn is your one word you know
I think I think learn the desire and
willingness to to go through crap and
learn and get better you could you could
pick up anything and I think I'm the
Testament to that in that I suck at the
start of my channel if you go back it's
embarrassing watching my first content
it's really really bad but I just kept
learning and said I can get better I'm
going to improve I'm going to keep
working I'm gonna keep getting better
and and it worked and so more than any
specific skill I think it's the mindset
it's it's the desire to learn and
understand that I can do better if you
take that into any field uh and match
you with some self-awareness I think
you're set like there's so many
different ways to win as an entrepreneur
there's so many different ways yes you
may not win the same way that Gary ve
win and so to have the self-awareness to
know hey I'm I'm Mara I'm great at
talking to people I'm going to do a talk
show and then you can model success and
you can learn from Oprah and you can
learn from Larry King and you can learn
from all the great talk show hosts and
model some of their Styles and every
time you do that you learn a little bit
more to be a better Mara and keep
growing and keep getting better how do
you balance your your home life your
work life what just balance look like to
you do you do you have a routine can you
tell us a little bit about it yeah I
think ultimately My Philosophy is your
actions have to map to your Ambitions so
what are your Ambitions what do you want
to create what's the what's your perfect
dream life I think part of being an
entrepreneur is we get to pick what we
do I mean that's why we become
entrepreneurs we want to create the
schedule that we want for ourselves so
what does a dream life look like for you
and it's not going to be all day working
you don't want to spend all day work on
your business um you also don't want to
spend all day with your kids and you
don't want to spend all day with your
spouse so what does that balance and mix
look like for you and and that's a very
personal question I think part of where
we struggled is we compare Our Lives to
somebody else it's like oh well she's
such a super mom and she's doing all
these things and so I suck because I'm
not doing it like she's doing or like
he's doing it where this is a very
personal question and
so what I do is uh I have different
dates for different things so every
morning uh start de with my morning
routine part of that includes if we're
talking family time part of that
includes me walk with my wife so this
morning we walk to Whole Foods we took
the dogs out it's starting to get warm
here in Toronto Canada which is amazing
uh grabbed the Americano from Whole
Foods walk back and just set up our
morning what are you working on today
what you know how is your sleep just
connecting grounding getting some sun in
our face getting some fresh air hanging
with the dogs like I like just that
connection in the morning to Nature and
to my my pets and my wife and you know
it's a half hour walk um and then from
there I'm mostly working like today's
been back to back to back calls and
podcasts and training and just work work
work work work work work uh I have five
minute gaps in between and my wife works
with me she's in the other room I saw
her outside on the balcony with the dog
so pop in say hi give her a kiss come
back like little micro moments like that
but for the most part it's just work um
and then different days different
different actions today's we're filming
this on a Thursday that's my public
facing day where it's non-stop
interviews and podcast we'll do
something every night to hang out I'll
spend some time um just with my wife
usually watching something relaxing with
the dogs on the couch kind of thing I'll
spend some time with my son uh often
like playing Minecraft or something fun
that he likes to do um and then that's
usually Monday to Friday weekends are
different story Saturday is funay and so
Saturday we always do something for the
family that's not not work related and
not uh admin related so we're not going
GR shopping we're not doing uh you know
condo cleaning or house cleaning or
whatever but something something fun
like there's a street festival or we're
gonna go for a hike outside or we're g
to try a new restaurant or just
something that we want to do and then
Sunday is family admin day where that's
all of the full the laundry and clean up
the office and you know like whatever
you have to do to kind of
run oh I love this run run our lives I
don't think people grow up with a
healthy perspective on money some people
like you alluded to think money is
everything and and the next person
coming in that's my next purse and
that's my next she's my next suit or
she's my next car or whatever uh and
money is is everything and there's other
people though which I find a lot more in
my community who think money is the root
of all evil right it's actually the love
of money is the root of all evil but it
gets shorten to money is the root of all
evil and so you're afraid to make money
and you think money is bad and money is
you shouldn't make money you have to
make money I think money needs to be
especially want to be an entrepreneur
money has to be in your top five list of
priorities it just can't be number
one but it's not number 1,000 either
like you have to learn how to monetize
and make money because if you want to
serve if you're stuck in some job that
you hate and you're only serving for
free on the weekends and evenings you're
limited to how much you can help but if
you can turn this into a full-time
business and then hire people on your
team and now you've got 10 20 100 people
working for you all aligned to this
mission that you're on to save people
right
imagine the impact you can have because
you learned how to make money it just
can't be number one so the last section
of the book talks about how to turn that
those ideas you got that passion you got
the big heart into something that can
actually serve the world but also make
you money how do you feel
about this kind of like world that is
going speeding so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of place so first step like
the first step for me is flipping it to
get excited so when something new comes
out it's like okay I'm excited to I'm
excited to go learn that thing AI comes
out cool let's go let's go learn about
AI it's like expecting to suck at it I
don't know anything about AI I don't
know how to program AI didn't know how
to do anything inside of AI and okay
let's go learn we're we're filming this
video on the on the the day after
Instagram or Facebook just launches
threads right right so threads just come
out it's a Twitter competition and most
people are like oh my gosh threads
another social media thing why do we
need another place to go and doom scroll
on and great like I'm a let me learn
about threads this is exciting I just
try to teach myself that when there's
something new let's go learn it it's
exciting because the rate of change is
not going to go slower right I agree so
so this becomes your key uh adaptation
Tech technique is that anytime something
new comes out get excited go learn about
it this is how you can start to win and
for anybody who is earlier on in their
Journey whenever something new comes out
that actually becomes your secret hack
to go off and win so if you're trying to
get started and you're on Twitter it
might be hard for you to to win right
now because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they built
up Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right
now because he doesn't want to start
over right this is the problems like
people don't want to start over and I
don't know anything about Brad Pit no
shade at Brad uh but like some people
make the jump like Will Smith make the
jump and like starts blowing up on
YouTube but a lot of people don't a lot
of people stick to one platform and then
they they slowly become irrelevant and
so when new comes up this is your chance
to go off and win like you might not
beat Joe Rogan at podcasting but you can
beat him on threads or you can get close
to him on threads and a lot of the
people who are are winning in that first
platform just don't want to go and start
over on the second one and so this is
your chance to get ahead and so whether
it's AI whether it's threads whether
it's an update to the YouTube algorithm
whether it's whatever the thing is
there's more
coming and there and there's more coming
too so training yourself to be the
person who gets excited for new changes
because that's your chance to go and win
and have a bigger impact make more money
like whatever actually drives you spread
more faith right whatever actually is
driving you this is your opportunity to
go off and do it and so for me that's
always been the default where like okay
why I don't it's always been a default I
think I've trained myself um to get more
excited about the new things that are
coming up uh and I just go in with a
student mind I expect to suck you know
like I don't somebody asked me about
threads today like hey what's your
thread strategy like I don't know I'm
two days in like I'm trying to figure it
out I don't even know what this is yet
I'm I'm maybe not the smartest person
but I'm I'm trying to understand it as
we go or when some new AI tool drops
okay let's understand what the heck this
thing even does and learning how to use
it so but it's just getting excited
about it and putting in a little bit of
effort to learn how to do it because so
many people they just get stuck on I
don't know how and it's new and scary
and so I don't do anything where really
you're actually not that far away from
making momentum if you just put in a
little bit of effort what do you sell
like what's the main thing that you want
to
sell like um right now I have my books I
don't have many many other things maybe
I could come up with many other things
but now I have my books and I I am a
speaker so but I haven't been speaking
quite much I I am in Europe haven't been
much further on
out
cool so anything that you want to sell
should be a series on your channel so if
you want to sell books then the best
thing to do is think about people who
can recommend your books and have them
as a guest on your
show so we're using the show for
business development so who can push a
lot of books and it might be
entrepreneurs it might be other
influencers it might be people from the
book Community it might be uh book
agents anybody in the book world people
with a big list that they might send it
to people who run book clubs right how
do you have them as guests on your show
and we we almost don't even care how
well the video does in terms of metrics
on YouTube Facebook whatever it's for
you the build a relationship so that
they get to know you love you trust you
and your book becomes the next thing
that they use in their book club right
if you made a list of the top 500 book
clubs in
America and then reached out to all of
those leaders who run the book clubs and
have them as guests on your show you're
going to get a lot more people reading
your book oh okay being intentional
taking risk while you're young because a
lot of people don't like understand that
like I mean people that are listening
that are like in christianized spot like
we're young and like we don't have a lot
to worry about like now is the time to
take that risk like if you ever had the
thought of being an entrepreneur I feel
like now is the time to like try it out
because jobs are going to be available
like later down the road yeah you know I
think now is now is always the right
answer like it's easier when you're when
you're young but I'm I'm 38 now 38 39 in
May great like if I was in a job that I
hated as a 38 39 year old and I hated my
life now is the time what I'm going to
wait another 30 years of working for
some company that I ate you know like
now is always the right time now was
people wait for the perfect time it
never comes and then and then you end up
in a retirement home regretting your
entire life so now is always the time
what is your
philosophy uh in terms of as you studied
all these people what do you think for
those listening what are some of the
core elements of success that would be
useful to our listeners if you
will so I think the the number one rule
that comes up consistently we've we've
covered people who are I started just
entrepreneurs and we've expanded to
athletes and musicians and innovators
and politicians and like anybody who's
had success from any Walk of Life the
number one thing that it all that they
all have in common is the love for the
work that they're doing of yes loving
the the results but like loving the
actual
work often even when it doesn't make
sense for a lot of these people starting
up they have this passion for XYZ but
didn't make sense like there was no
business model attached to it I don't
know how it's going to work out and so
making the big decisions with the heart
and not the head you make the big
decisions with the heart and then use
your head to help figure out how you're
going to make it work is a consistent
theme across um all the people that we
profiled uh at some at some degree
you're gonna have people who will will
hate on your idea will tell you that it
won't work especially the bigger the
idea you have the more people are going
to hate against it you know like a lot
of people say TJ we don't have greatness
within us come on man like what are you
trying to do and like and the bigger the
mission you have the more people fight
because it's changed they they want to
protect the status quo and so if
nobody's hating on what you're doing
then you're not you're not actually
living a great life um in my opinion you
don't have important enough Mission and
so expecting people to to hate on on
your ideas uh and then be able to deal
with it I think are some of the key
things that keep coming up over and over
and over and over again across all
successful
people
[Music]
to destroy the negativity in your life
watch the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there that negative
voice inside your head that's telling
you that you suck and you can't do it
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up